pour terminer complètement ce journal la
musique avec le groupe clash pendant une
semaine à paris le groupe clash a fait
vibrer les murs du théâtre mogador le
groupe clash c'est un groupe de quatre
jeunes anglais venus des banlieues
ouvrières de londres il a joué le musée
que très dur sans concession mais le
résultat est déjà apprécié de plus en
plus dans tous les pays
le reportage de freddy auxerre et c'est
par là que nous terminerons complètement
cette édition d'antenne 2010
pour
faux
avec paris
g
patassé
fait mieux poser
maintenant ils sont à paris donc encore
une semaine et c'est là
la semaine se termine et
c'est donc l'événement le
l'un des événements les plus importants
pour eux il y avait aussi à l'époque le
mais finalement marsan puis maintenant
bon c'est paris pour une semaine
je crois que paris a été choisi parce
que c'est l'endroit où il voulait jouer
le plus après new york une semaine à new
york
l'iphone semaine à paris
on
le
c'est
et
non